i would love to hear eddie murphy just
do anything
live on stage as a stand-up comic but
because there's such
pressure to be better than you were
before you you're not only judged by
your past specials
and then some people say gee was much
better back then because he talked about
this now he's afraid to talk about you
know you're so
judged that it literally can clam a guy
up i talked to him
you know we're not we're not talking
about a guy that i don't have access to
we're talking about a real friend a real
mentor i've talked to him
eddie what the [ __ ] are you doing get on
stage i don't know
i don't know man maybe maybe eddie is
still
two day i will say two day from a
from a joke to joke perspective i'm
gonna go ahead and i'm gonna give dave
chappelle the crown he deserves in my
opinion
he deserves it dave chappelle it's just
he's just operating on a different
frequency
right now and it's interesting murphy
when i tell you if you sit in a room
with eddie
you will laugh from the beginning of the
day to the
end he loves to be funny
he loves to joke he loves to laugh
he loves to tell stories he loves it he
still has a passion for it
there is just no want a reason to step
back into that place
until he feels like he absolutely
positively
is ready for that moment and he says
until he has that
then then why do it and i understand i
understand him like he's reached a level
of security and happiness
and and and greatness in his career
why jeopardize any of that when i hear
when i'm trying to imagine that you are
now friends with eddie murphy i mean
close friends as a kid growing up i'm
sure you idolized him but now
when you're in a position that you've
earned your chops and you've become very
famous for being funny in your own right
is it hard for you to be your natural
self to be
authentic around a guy like eddie when
do you start getting comfortable with
these guys that you idolized growing up
and now you're
suddenly friends with them there's the
shock period
of when you can't believe your
surroundings there's the shock period of
holy [ __ ] like look at the circle that
i'm in
yeah and there goes rock there's
chappelle holy [ __ ]
there's god damn it there's a thing
where you where you had that and then
there's a moment
when you realize the people that are
there
are just dope good people chappelle
orchestrated the dinner
this is the biggest comedic night in my
life
it's chris dave me
eddie tucker we sit down at dinner
and the dinner the dinner is so [ __ ]
great
it's so great and in the middle of
realizing how great it is i realized why
it's because we were all listening to
eddie
give stories with [ __ ]
pizzazz personality telling us what
happened that's not his [ __ ] i
remember man he told me
and we're dying laughing and none of us
none of us are trying to one-up the
story
none of us are telling other story we're
all listening and feeding off of eddie's
energy and it was one of those things
where now when you look back at it it
was us
bowing down to the [ __ ] goat in our
mind
regardless of where we are in our
careers eddie was at the head of that
table
we all sat around eddie at the head of
the table we ate we listened to eddie we
joked we laughed we [ __ ] toasted
glasses man
and and we we shared a bond
but it was one of respect it was one of
not just mutual respect
but but looking at eddie going you're
the reason why
you're you're the reason why we can sit
at this table like
we these doors got kicked open because
of what you did
you